Per molti uomini la domanda vuole che io
faccia una mossa può sembrare come
camminare su un filo sospeso, fare una
mossa troppo presto e rischi di
interpretare male la situazione,
aspettare troppo a lungo e potresti
perdere del tutto l'occasione.
Fortunatamente, sebbene ogni persona sia
diversa, ci sono segnali comuni che una
donna può mostrare quando è aperta al
fatto che tu faccia il passo successivo.
Che si tratti di iniziare una
conversazione più profonda, invitarla ad
uscire o tentare un bacio. In questo
video vedremo cinque segnali che una
donna vuole che tu faccia una mossa.
Prima di iniziare, smetti di
accontentarti di relazioni tiepide,
legami d'amore, psicologia delle
relazioni, seduzione consapevole,
attrazione autentica e crescita
personale è il libro che ti svela come
accendere connessioni profonde,
sviluppare un'attrazione magnetica e
alimentare una crescita personale
travolgente. Link descrizione. numero
uno ti dà la sua completa attenzione.
Nel complesso e delicato gioco della
connessione romantica, riconoscere
quando una donna desidera che tu faccia
una mossa può sembrare come decifrare un
linguaggio sottile di gesti, espressioni
e segnali emotivi.
Uno dei segnali più forti che potrebbe
indicare il suo desiderio di una
connessione più profonda è quando ti
dedica alla sua completa attenzione. In
un mondo pieno di distrazioni, dove gli
smartphone vibrano costantemente e le
obbligazioni quotidiane ci trascinano da
ogni parte, l'attenzione totale è una
forma rara e potente di interesse.
Quando una donna sceglie di mettere via
il telefono e dirige tutta la sua
presenza verso di te, non è solo
cortesia, è intenzione. Sta scegliendo
consapevolmente di essere pienamente nel
momento con te. Il suo linguaggio del
corpo spesso riflette questa intenzione.
Può inclinarsi leggermente verso di te,
mantenere un contatto visivo costante e
rispondere in modo attento alle tue
parole. Questi segnali creano uno spazio
in cui può fiorire un'interazione
significativa. La sua attenzione non si
limita ad ascoltare, si impegna
attivamente, magari facendo domande di
approfondimento o mostrando genuina
curiosità per i tuoi pensieri e le tue
esperienze.
Questo tipo di energia concentrata parla
più forte delle parole. Quando una donna
ti fa sentire come se fossi l'unica
persona nella stanza, spesso è il suo
modo di dirti che è pronta a vederti
come qualcosa di più di un semplice
conoscente. Numero due, rimane anche
dopo che la conversazione dovrebbe
essere finita. Nel mondo delle
interazioni umane gran parte della
comunicazione avviene oltre le parole.
Segnali sottili, pause e gesti spesso
hanno più significato di quello che
viene detto. Uno dei segnali più chiari,
eppure più facilmente trascurati, che
una donna possa voler che tu faccia una
mossa è quando rimane lì anche dopo che
la conversazione è naturalmente giunta
alla fine. Questo rimanere non è
casuale. Quando un dialogo si avvia alla
conclusione, la maggior parte delle
persone comincia a prendere le distanze.
magari guarda il telefono, cambia
postura o dice un educato, "Beh, devo
andare". Se invece lei resiste a questi
segnali di chiusura e rimane presente,
nonostante non ci sia alcuna necessità,
probabilmente sta creando spazio perché
accada qualcosa di più. Può rallentare
il passo se state camminando, esitare
prima di congedarsi o mantenere il
contatto visivo come se stesse
aspettando che tu dica qualcosa per
prolungare il momento. Questo silenzio,
questa pausa è spesso un invito gentile
a fare il passo successivo, chiederle il
numero, proporre di rivedervi o dire
qualcosa che renda l'interazione più
personale. Numero tre, suggerisce piani
futuri o lascia spiragli. Quando cerchi
di capire se una donna è interessata a
fare un passo in avanti, presta
attenzione a quando suggerisce attività
future o lascia frasi aperte che
sembrano invitarti a partecipare. Se
dice qualcosa come dovremmo farlo
qualche volta non è una frase casuale, è
un invito velato, una possibilità che ti
lascia per prendere l'iniziativa.
A volte parla di un evento o di un posto
senza dire con chi ci andrà, lasciando
spazio a te per proporti. Il modo in cui
lo dice e la frequenza con cui lo ripete
sono indizi forti del fatto che voglia
vederti di nuovo. Numero 4, risponde
positivamente a un flirt leggero. Se
noti che sorride, mantiene il contatto
visivo, ride anche alle tue battute più
leggere o gioca fisicamente con te come
toccarti leggermente il braccio è un
segnale chiaro di apertura. Alcuni gesti
come avvicinarsi, toccarsi i capelli o
imitare i tuoi movimenti indicano che è
a suo agio e attratta. La distanza che
mantiene, il tono di voce e l'energia
che mette nella conversazione sono
indicatori preziosi. Numero cinque,
menziona di essere single o disponibile.
Quando una donna inserisce nella
conversazione, senza essere stata
sollecitata, frasi che indicano di
essere single, è un segnale potente. Può
dire che passerà il fine settimana da
sola o che non ha impegni, oppure
parlare in modo leggero di brutti
appuntamenti o del fatto che le app di
incontri non stanno funzionando. Il
momento in cui sceglie di rivelare
questo dettaglio è importante. Se lo fa
in un contesto più intimo, dopo aver
riso o condiviso qualcosa di personale,
probabilmente vuole che tu colga il
messaggio. È un modo sottile per dire la
strada è libera se vuoi farti avanti.
Smetti di accontentarti di relazioni
tiepide, legami d'amore, psicologia
delle relazioni, seduzione consapevole,
attrazione autentica e crescita
personale è il libro che ti svela come
accendere connessioni profonde,
sviluppare un'attrazione magnetica e
alimentare una crescita personale
travolgente. Link nella descrizione.